se me ocurre inventar dos empresas de
zapatos una que se llama ben y la otra
que se llama jayson y ambas cotizan en
la bolsa de valores esto quiere decir
que ambas acciones cotizan en la bolsa
no sé supongamos en la bolsa de nasdaq
en nueva york o en cualquier otra bolsa
y también vamos a suponer que el precio
de estas acciones es siempre creciente
el último precio de cierre de las
acciones de la empresa ben estaba en
21.50 pesos por acción mientras que el
cierre de las acciones de la empresa
jameson está dada por 12 pesos por
acción lo que vamos a ver en este vídeo
es por qué son importantes este tipo de
negocios ahora bien también vamos a
suponer que ambas empresas tienen diez
mil acciones recuerden que una acción es
una parte fraccionaria del patrimonio
neto no es una porción de los bienes ni
del activo es más bien una parte
fraccionaria en la que se divide el
capital social de una empresa bueno
entonces los activistas están dispuestos
a pagar 21 50 pesos por acción en el
caso de las acciones deben pero como
tienen 10.000 acciones entonces al
multiplicar el precio
con el número de acciones le vamos a
llamar capitalización bursátil que en
este caso es 21 50 por 10 mil 3 200 215
mil 215 mil pesos es decir la
capitalización bursátil de una compañía
la podemos definir como la dimensión
económica de una empresa es decir el
patrimonio disponible para la venta y
compra de los activos de una empresa y
aquí está la definición más importante
de todo el vídeo en el caso de la
compañía deben la capitalización
bursátil es de 215 mil pesos por lo
tanto vamos a escribir la capitalización
bursátil bursátil con acento en la ahora
bien como ya sabemos si comparamos el
precio de una acción de la empresa bien
es mayor al precio de nación en la
empresa de jason y como ambas tienen la
misma cantidad de acciones es decir
están divididas en partes equitativas
por lo tanto la empresa vean tendrá más
capitalización bursátil que la empresa y
jason es más vamos a calcular de una vez
la capitalización bursátil de la empresa
de axxion que son 120 mil pesos
es 12 pesos que costaba la acción por 10
mil acciones 120 mil pesos el mercado
nos va a decir o inclusive en los libros
podemos encontrar esto que el capital
basado en cuánto es el valor de nuestros
activos es de 135.000 en el caso de la
empresa de bien mientras que el mercado
evalúa esta empresa en la capitalización
bursátil de 215 mil pesos por ejemplo en
el caso de jason la empresa en lugar de
estar valuada en los 35 mil pesos del
capital el mercado lo evalúa en el
precio de 120 mil pesos de su respectiva
capitalización bursátil de hecho en el
siguiente vídeo vamos a pensar el por
qué el mercado está actuando o está
evaluando este negocio de esta manera y
espero que todo esto les dé una buena
noción de la diferencia que hay entre el
capital de la empresa y la
capitalización bursátil de esta misma al
final hay que tener muy en cuenta esta
diferencia cuando pensamos en el valor
contable